Okay. So as discussed uh on Monday for
the next uh for this lecture actually
we're going to go through some of the
key concepts behind the classical
optimization. So nonlinear optimization
problem where we solve over a finite
amount of decision variables. An idea
here is not that this is a class about
optimization. This is a class about
optimal learning based control. But many
of the insights from classical
optimization carry over to the field of
optimal and learning based control. So
in particular what we did uh uh on
Monday was to define what an
optimization problem is and what does it
mean to for a point or a vector. I will
use this uh terminology interchangeably
to be a local minimum or a global
minimum of a given objective function f.
What we're going to do now is a couple
of things. So first derive basic
necessary conditions for optimality. So
these are conditions that essentially
say if a given point or vector is a
local minimum then something has to
happen. And typically people use these
necessary optimality conditions for
example as a filters to filter out
candidates for optimality. The fact that
you fulfill a necessary optimality
condition doesn't guarantee that that
point is a local minimum. But if it does
not fulfill but if a point does not
fulfill that necessary optimality
condition there is not a chance that
that point can be a local minimum.
So how do we derive necessary conditions
for optimality? So the idea is that uh
you assume that you are at a local
minimum and you see whether there are
any particular insights that you can
derive from the fact that a point is a
local minimum. Particularly the idea is
to reason in terms of what happens when
we perturb
a local minimum denoted as XAR by a
small perturbation delta X and we try to
find some general rule that can serve as
our necessary optimality condition.
Specifically from basic calculus we know
that if f is differentiable
f of xar plus delta x where delta x is a
small displacement.
So you're just moving a tiny bit out of
xar in some direction
is approximately equal to f of xar
plus gradient of f evaluated at xar
times uh delta x
prime means transpose.
So you should be familiar with uh this
notion. Of course there are some error
terms here but the idea is that as delta
x gets closer and closer
the first order term. So the term that
includes the derivative becomes the
dominant one and so the other terms can
be neglected and so roughly speaking we
can look at this approximation as it
deemed being an equality. Okay.
Or one can go one step further and
consider a second order approximation
where in addition to the first order
term you also account for a second order
term this is the action of the function
f. So basically the matrix that collects
the second order derivatives.
Are you okay with this? Yeah. Are you
taking the gradient over the derivative
of f or is it you're taking the gradient
over f the function f?
>> Oh no gradient of f is just notation. So
this is a the naba symbol. So by
definition
naba f is defined as the vector of uh
the derivatives with respect to each
variable. Oh yeah.
X2 dot dot dot dot derivative XN
>> this one.
>> Oh yeah just transpose. uh it could be
like T or here in this class I use other
transpose of or
so on the transpose in this class I will
either use the symbol capital T or prime
um yeah same thing here
okay so so far nothing uh uh
particularly interesting
now Let's
apply the fact that we are assuming that
xar is a local minimum.
So if xar is a local minimum by the
definition of a local minimum if I move
around that point the function f has to
assume a larger value. This is by
definition for a point to be a local
minimum. Which means that f of xar plus
delta x minus f of xar
has to be greater than or equal to zero.
This is because we're assuming that xar
is a local minimum. Which means that if
we move around then the function f has
to take on a larger value.
But if this is the case and assuming
that delta x is small so this relation
can be taken as an inequality. So this
implies
So this implies that uh the
remember that f of xar plus delta x
minus f of xar is equal to the gradient
times delta x. So that implies
worse
worse.
This implies that gradient of f
evaluated xar time delta x has to be
greater than or equal to zero.
I write this killer product
in expanded form. So I carry out the
product. So this implies that the
summation from i = 1 to n or the partial
derivative of f with respect to x i
times delta x i
is greater than or equal to zero. Well
the delta x i added this displacement
with respect to each i coordinate. Delta
x is a vector
with displacement delta x1 delta x2
delta dot delta xn.
Any questions about that?
So remember
that if xar is a local minimum then f of
xar plus delta x has to be greater than
or equal to f of xar for all possible
delta x. small enough.
That was for all possible delta x. Let's
just fix a few possible choices for the
delta x. So let's consider displacement
of the type delta x equal to epsilon
where epsilon is a small scalar positive
number
say 1 0 0.
So this will be um say delta x
one or another possible choice for the
vector delta x could be delta x2 equal
epsilon where all the coordinates are
zero except the second one and so on.
So this is just a specific choice of the
attacks. This relation has to be true
for all possible choices. I'm just
selecting a few possible choices.
But if I select delta x in this way and
then I carry out this color product,
you'll see that all those products are
equal to zero except for the i
coordinate.
So if I start plugging in all these
possible choices of displacements, I
start getting conditions of the type
epsilon delta uh partial to f to xi
time 1 greater than or equal to zero.
But I also take can take the negative of
this one. So I get minus epsilon partial
dative f to x i * 1 less than or equal
to zero. absolutely small positive
number. So this I can just cancel it out
from this inequality. So essentially I
get a bunch of inequality of this type.
So wrapping up we have found that if xar
is a local minimum
then each partial derivative has to be
simultaneously greater than or equal to
zero or less than or equal to zero. So
what what is the only number that is
simultaneously greater than or equal to
0 less than or equal to 0? Z. So
basically we've just proven that each
partial if xar is a local minimum then
each partial derivative of f with
respect to x i has to be equal to zero.
Putting all those results together we
get to the celebrated necessary
optimality condition that says that at a
local minimum if xar is a local minimum
then the gradient has to be equal to
zero.
In the one-dimensional case,
say that you have a function.
Say that you have a function like this
one.
So this is a local minimum. And indeed
you see that here the derivative is
equal to zero.
Here the derivative is equal to zero but
this is clearly not a local minimum.
This is a local maximum. So that shows
that the fact that the gradient is equal
to zero is a necessary condition for
optimality but is not a sufficient
condition for optimality.
And probably already know about this but
my point here is just to reiterate the
concept of a necessary optimality
condition because as I said it will
become quite useful as we move on.
Now of course we can go one step
further. So so far we have used a first
order approximation of a function but we
can also use a second order
approximation of a function and see
whether the fact that the point is a
local minimum tells us something about a
function beyond just the first order
derivative.
Well remember that uh the
second order approximation of a function
reads like the following. So you have a
linear term and a quadratic term.
Quadratic because the delta x multiply
each other.
So by the same reasoning as before, if
xar is a local minimum, this different
has to be greater than or equal to zero,
which means that this term also has to
be greater than or equal to zero. But we
have just proven that the local minimum
the gradient is equal to zero. So we are
left with the fact that if a point is a
local minimum then this quadratic
product has to be greater than or equal
to zero. A delta x is arbitrary.
It can be so for example if you're into
d can be any vector in you know any
possible direction.
So what is this telling us with respect
to the action of the function?
there has to be positive semi-definite.
Actually that's a definition of a
positive semidefinite matrix. So if the
function is twice differentiable we get
the strengthen
necessary optimality condition that not
only the gra has to be equal to zero but
isan has to be positive semidefinite
we us to the
nc theorem necessary optimality
condition theorem let xar be
unconstrained local minimum of a
function that maps a vector of n
variables to a scalar that is a real
number. R is the set of real numbers. RM
is the set of vectors with components in
the real space. Assume that f F1 is C1.
C1 means that the function is
differentiable with is continuously
differentiable.
And let's assume that X star is an
unconstrained local minimum within an
open set.
um
then the gradient has to be equal to
zero. And additionally, if f is twice
differentiable, the hash has to be
positive uh semi uh definite.
A reminder, an open set is loosely
speaking
uh a set that contains a ball around
each point. So basically set that
doesn't contain its boundary.
This is important because for example
say that you have this a function that
is defined between a and b. Is this
point here a local minimum?
Well it is right. So if you move in any
allow allowable direction then the value
of the function increases.
But is the derivative equal to zero?
clearly enough because this will be the
derivative. So here what's happening is
that this point is not inside the open
set is indeed on the boundary. So this
necessary condition only holds if you're
not on the boundary of the domain of
your function. So that's what the open
set statement here is referring to.
If you're within the open set, yes, then
if there is a local minimum, then the
derivative has to be equal to zero.
Yeah.
>> So when you say the open set, does that
mean the same thing as the constraint?
>> No. So if um
basically so here
so you can have like an interval
like this one, right?
So the interval does have constraints.
So has a lower bound as an upper bound
but does not contain its boundary.
So this notion of open interval or
closed interval.
Does it make sense?
>> Basically you don't want to pick points
that are on the boundary of your domain.
That's what he's saying.
>> Constraint problem.
>> Constraint. That's perfect. Then of
course the space of real numbers doesn't
have a boundary. So yes, you're in an
open set. And so this holds true. No
problem. This is more for the case of a
function that for example is defined in
uh that maps all numbers from AB into
the real numbers. So the domain is
actually between A and B. You want to
make sure that you apply the NOC
condition only for points strictly
between A and B. Otherwise you might get
a spurious situation whereby you have a
point that is a local minimum but is not
uh doesn't have a um derivative equal to
zero.
That's all I'm saying. But the moment
you move away from the boundary then for
a point to have any chance to be local
minimum then the derivative has to be
equal to zero.
This is more of technicality by the way.
So then a natural question is can we
strengthen this to a sufficient
optimality condition. So a condition
that says if something happens then that
point is a local minimum.
And here I'm just going to give you an
intuition.
Say that now we strengthen
the condition whereby the the aen now is
not just positive some definite but is
positive definite which means that as
you move locally around xar
the value of the function
increases.
So this suggests
that uh strengthening the condition a to
be positive definite will lead us to a
sufficient optimality condition. Of
course the proof has to be a little bit
more involved because there are some
additional terms that we're not
accounting approximation. So we should
do use a little bit of limit arguments
to make sure that this actually is
mathematically rigorous. But the
intuition is that if
uh the action is positive definite, the
gradient is equal to zero. The function
locally around xar is essentially a
ball, right? And so uh the value of the
function increases immediately after you
leave xar which means that the the being
positive definite is indeed a sufficient
condition which is encapsulated in the
theorem here.
So for example, one way to use these
conditions is that uh you look at all
the points for which the gradient is
equal to zero
and then maybe you get six points that
satisfy the condition and then you
evaluate the function at each one of
these points and then you apply some
other arguments to see whether that is
indeed the local minimum or not.
One special case that will become
important later is that of a convex
function. Probably you already know what
a convex function is but just in case
you don't know about it is specific
class of function that in a way
have a behavior
that is very nice and then I will
specify later what I mean by nice but
there still no linear functions. So how
are convex functions defined? So let's
start from the domain of a convex
function. A convex function is defined
over a convex domain. What is a convex
domain? Well, a set a set is set is said
to be convex
if whenever you pick
two points
the line joining them is contained in
the set. So this is a context set.
Mathematically
a set a subset of
the ukidian space is referred to as a
convex set. If whenever you pick two
point x and y the line joining x and y
is contained in the set. So this set is
convex.
This set is not convex. Right? Because
if I pick these two points then this
line leaves the set which means that the
set is not convex.
So let's consider a set C which is
convex. A function F is called convex if
this condition holds. What does this
condition say graphically?
So let's just
draw a diagram.
So you have a function.
So you have x, you have y,
and then you have a function such as
this one.
So you pick any point between x and y.
So for example this point here. So this
will be uh alpha x
+ 1 - alpha y.
This will be f ofx.
This will be f of y.
So the function is convex if the line
segments between any two points on the
graph of the function lies above the
graph.
So this will be the segment that joins
f_sub_x and f_sub_y.
The function is convex if that line is
above the graph of the function.
So for example this function is
convex
and then
this function what do you think is not
convex because for example if you pick
two points
then the line will be below the graph.
So you might say why do you care about
uh such functions
from the point of view optimization you
care for two reasons. So these functions
are special in that a local minimum of f
over c is also global minimum.
In general nar optimization a local
minimum is not guaranteed to be a global
minimum. you might have many local
minima and then some of them would be
global minima.
In addition, if f is strictly convex,
which means that this inequality holds
strict for all points not in the
boundary, then there is at least uh at
most one global minimum.
Even more interestingly, if f is convex
and is differentiable,
then the gradient being equal to zero is
a necessary a sufficient condition for a
vector xar to be a global minimum of c.
So this is nice on two different
accounts. Not only gradient equal to
zero is a sufficient condition as
opposed to just being a necessary
condition as it is the case for general
nonlinear function but also is a
sufficient condition not just for local
optimality but indeed for global
optimality which is great because
essentially means that a very local test
so essentially taking a gradient means
that you're just looking at a function
very locally tells you something a
property about the entire function.
So you can think how computationally
convex functions are much easier to deal
with. That's basically the intuition I
want to give here.
>> Yeah.
>> You mentioned if the complex function is
different.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. For example, if you have a king
Yeah.
Okay. So we'll get back to this later.
In particular, one of the strategies we
look at to compute uh trajectories or to
solve openloop uh uh optimal control
problems will be to uh successively
convexify
uh a function, solve a convex
optimization problem, get a new
solution, reconvexify the problem and
iterate. It turns out that this strategy
is one of the most popular strategies to
do trajectory optimization for uh
robotic systems of all sort. So we'll
come back to convex optimization later.
So that's essentially what I wanted to
say about necessary optimality
conditions. They are useful to filter
out the candidates. They form the basis
to derive a computational algorithm to
compute local minima as we will see in a
second. They can also be used for
sensitivity analysis purposes. So to see
how much a local minimum
might change if we change some of the
problem data based some of the value of
the parameters in your problem like the
mass of your robotic system even though
the sensitivity analysis aspect is a bit
beyond the scope of this class.
All right. So let's then move
to today's lecture.
So, so far I've talked about necessary
optimality conditions, but you know
often times it's quite unwieldly to
compute all the points that satisfy the
condition gradient equal to zero. So,
we're interested in computational
methods that directly give us the uh a
candidate for optimality.
So that's what what we're going to see
next and then we're going to conclude
the lecture by expanding what we know
from the field of unconstrained
optimization to the setting where we
have a constraints.
Constraints are indeed as something we
have to deal with in this class because
at the minimum we have a one constraint
we have to deal with which is the basic
constraints we have to deal with
the dynamics of our body I mean of
course we cannot go the speed of light
so that's a constraint on our motion so
we can optimize as much as we want but
uh if you have a Fiat 500 you don't get
the performance of a Ferrari. So that's
probably unfortunate fact of life. So
yeah, so at least there is dynamics as a
constraint.
Okay. So
let's talk a little bit about
computational methods. Of course, this
class will be quite deep in
computational methods to solve optional
control problems. And what we're going
to discuss now again is quite
pedagogical with respect to what we're
going to discuss next.
And particularly I mean there are many
different ways to attempt to solve a
nine optimization problem but a specific
way we look at is referred to as
gradient methods
which is a particular class of iterative
methods. So what are iterative methods?
So the idea is that we want to solve our
unconstrained nine optimization problem
and we want to see whether we can find
uh
some rule
that starting from
uh do I use the superscript? Yes.
Starting from some initial guess of what
a local minimum could be. If you have no
idea, you can just say, well, your local
gas is 0000 0, just the origin.
Then you start producing a sequence of
uh
updated guesses.
And the idea is that uh you hope that
you have a rule that allows you to
update your guesses in such a way that f
of x0
is greater than of f of x1 is greater
than or equal f of x2
dot dot dot. So basically you try to
cons iteratively update your guess about
what a local minimum can be
with a property that at every new guess
the value of the function is below the
value of the function. of the previous
guess with a hope that after
sufficiently many updates the value of
the function has been reduced so much
that you have either reached a local
minimum or at least you're very close to
local minimum.
But the question of course is how do you
produce such a rule that allows you to
go through these iterates and in doing
so you um decrease the value of the
function. So for that we again use the
notion of tailor series approximation of
first order approximation of a function
specifically.
Let's assume that uh we our current
guess is x some vector with you know a
components taking value 1 3 - 2 or 1 and
assignment.
So let's consider
the updated uh guess obtained by taking
x and subtracting
alpha times gradient of f evaluated at
x. I call this new guess
as x alpha. It is parameterized by
alpha. Alpha is a positive number.
So basically I am at x. Assume that you
are in
in the plane.
You are in the plane. So this is x.
This is uh
um gradient of f. Remember that the
gradient is a vector.
So x plus gradient of f leaves you here.
But of course this is parameterized by
alpha. So the larger the alpha, the more
far away you move from x.
Okay. So then
um
here
okay so I call it yeah x of alpha. So
then we know that f of x of alpha if
alpha is small enough so I don't move
too far away from x is equal to f ofx or
at least approximately equal to f ofx
plus
gradient of f of x
times
x alpha - X
but X alpha - X is equal to minus alpha
gradient of F of X.
So what we got is that
this is equal to or equal to f ofx
minus alpha gradient of f ofx. Here
there is a prime
prime gradient of f ofx.
But you know that for any vector V in Rn
V scalar product with V is equal to the
square
norm of V.
So this is equal to f ofx
minus alpha
gradient of f ofx².
the norm
is a non- negative number. In
particular, if the gradient is equal to
zero, well, you never you already know
that you are a candidate local minimum.
But if this not equal to zero, then this
number is positive, which means that
this number is negative, which means
that f of x alpha has a lower value than
f ofx.
So I've actually found a direction that
leads me to a value for f that is lower
than the value that I have at the
current gas.
Now interestingly as alpha gets larger
and larger which means that I move
farther and farther away from x this
becomes larger and larger which means
that f of x alpha becomes smaller and
smaller. So you might be tempted to say
so why don't you shoot alpha to a very
large number
why you don't do that I mean it's
tempting right why don't we sh choose
alpha equal a million
>> skip over
>> what's that
>> skip over the minimum
>> well from this mathematics there is
nothing that is telling us that is
skipping over the minimum we just can
arbitrarily decrease the value of the
function
>> exactly which actually is related to
what you were
that uh when we do the approximation the
first order approximation always keep in
mind that this is holds true for
uh points that are very close to x. So
the moment that you move farther away
you might think that you're doing
something useful but in reality you're
not relying on an approximation that is
telling you nothing about the value of
the function. So uh the result will no
longer be applicable.
Make sense? Effectively it means that
you go maybe overshoot a local minimum.
But mathematically one might say well uh
if the approximation was true actually
you could just arbitrarily uh decrease
the value of the function.
So this leads us to uh the class of
gradient methods. The class of gradient
methods is a bit broader in that you can
slightly generalize
this construction by just saying by
looking at update rules
whereby x of alpha
is more generally defined as x + alpha
d where
the gradient of f at x
scalar product with the direction d. So
this is a vector is greater than zero
sorry is less than zero. Of course if d
is equal to the minus of the gradient
which is exactly what we have here
automatically this is verified. But my
point here is that you don't need to
necessarily go along the gradient
direction. You can also pick some other
vector as long as this property is
satisfied because if you do so and you
do you go through the same steps again
you'll find out that f of f of x alpha
has lower value than f of x because this
color product the direction d is chosen
such that this scalar product is
negative. So geometrically what is
happening here? It's always good to have
a little bit of a geometric intuition.
So say that you have a function uh
defined on the real plane. So on the
plane of the board
and let's consider the so-cal
level set curves. So basically the set
of points x such as f of x is equal to a
given number c and then you can change
your number c is equal 1 2 and so on. So
this could be for example
the level set curve. So this will be f
ofx=
c3. This one f ofx= c2
f ofx. So for this one
f ofx= c1
for this one
and assume that the c3 is greater than
c2 is greater than c1 and so on.
So say that we are here at X
otherwise you should look at the proof
the gradient
of a function is orthogonal to the level
set curves. So basically what this
update rule is telling me is that I'm
looking at moving along these directions
here parameterized by alpha
or I can look at some other directions
like these ones as long as
the scalar product is negative which
means that I form an angle greater than
90°.
So this leads us to the celebrated class
of gradient methods rules whereby your
next guess. So your guess of what the
local minimum is at the iteration k +
one is equal to your previous guess
after k iterations plus alpha k dk.
Alpha k here doesn't mean alpha to the
power of k. here just means that the
step size as we will see in a second
might change in value depending on which
iteration you are at.
So if the gradient is different from
zero and that and DK is chosen such that
the angle between decay and the gradient
is greater than 90°
um and the step size alpha is chosen to
be positive. This is guaranteed to be um
an alpha ch carefully as we'll discuss
in a second. This might will lead to uh
descent.
Does it make sense? So gradient methods
again iterative algorithms where you
update your guess according to this rule
where the decay is a vector
with a property that the scalar product
with the gradient is is less than zero
and the step size alpha is chosen to be
positive
and typically we want to choose alpha
such that uh um the value at the new
guess is below the value at the previous
test practically you want to be careful
that you don't choose alpha too big.
>> Does the guarantee still hold if we take
into a composite order?
Yes, this will lead us uh to so you can
reason also the level of so there are
two things you can look you can still
use information from the hashion
as we will see uh in a second or you can
find more sophisticated algorithms that
consider uh more sophisticated
approximations we're going to look at
the former so I'll show you in one
second why actually we want to use
information also from the ashen not just
from the gradient
So of course there are two things that
uh are unresolved yet. So how do you
pick the descent direction? We said that
the gradient is a choice but really any
vector d as long as the scalar product
with the gradient is less than zero is a
valid choice. So which one do you pick
and how do you pick alpha? So alpha is
this number here which is referred to as
the step size.
So for the descent direction,
a popular class of descent directions is
defined as the gradient premultiplied by
a matrix that is positive definite.
Of course with this choice of the
descent direction
the um scalar the scalar product between
the gradient of f and d is negative
because we've chosen d to be positive
definite and we have a minus in front.
So this is a valid uh assignment of the
desend direction according to our rules.
But I just shifted the problem. So how
do we pick the direction? Now the
question is how do I pick this matrix D?
Two popular choices are you pick D
simply as the identity. So basically
just move along the negative gradient
direction or you pick D as we were
saying we were discussing with your
colleague as the inverse of the ashen.
Let me provide some intuition about why
we may want to consider different uh
choices of D without going too much into
the details about how one uh uh would
derive actually these rules.
Specifically, let's assume that we have
a function still defined in uh 2D
with a very nice level set carves. So,
they're just circles.
So, this is the domain of the function
x1 and x2.
So, the function would have values that
go uh orthogonal to the blackboard and
it will be a sort of a ball, right?
isotropic ball. So say that you're here.
So the gradient shoots in this direction
is orthogonal to the level set car.
Clearly this is the minimum because
we're talking about a ball. So the ball
is really at So basically the function
will be x1 squar plus x2 square. The
minimum will be at the origin. So you
move toward the negative direction of
the gradient. It's clear that you're
pointing around in the right direction.
You pick some alpha, maybe you end up
here. Then you recomp compute the
gradient, maybe you end up here, and
then finally you end up here. Great.
But what if we are
in a
in a situation like the following
whereby our function is still defined on
two dimensions, but now the level set
curves are ellipses.
So it's still a ball but now is
elongated in one direction and shrunk in
the other direction. So say that you are
here.
Now the gradient points in this
direction and the negative gradient
points in this direction. So as you see
actually you're not pointing
directly to the minimum. The minimum is
still zero. It's still a ball. is just
as is you know elongating this direction
and shrank in the lateral direction.
So this is to say that uh picking as a
descend direction the negative gradient
may not necessarily be the best thing to
do especially if you have a level set
curves are very elongated.
what happened is that uh you will
started zagging
a lot
so that and here I'm just giving you the
motivation there there could be a little
bit of derivation to do it that's why
you may want to use uh the ashen
intuitively the ashen gives you
information about the carvature of your
function so it allows you to better
inform
the uh direction that looks most
promising in terms of going to a minimum
So basically allows you to recognize
that this problem is different from this
problem. So you should do something
different. That's roughly speaking what
this um action here I'm doing. I won't
go uh far into the detail since this is
not a class on optimization.
Just to speak that there are different
choices.
This seems better. Of course it uses
more information. It use information
about the carvature of the function. But
everything comes at a cost here. The
cost is that if you want to implement
this descent direction action, not only
you have to compute a gradient, but you
also have to compute a hashion. So
basically a matrix of second order
derivatives. Depending on the size of
your nonlinear optimization problem,
maybe there is not enough bang for the
buck. Sure, you might decrease the
number of iterations because your
direction is better aligned with where
the local minimum eventually will be.
But every iteration is much more
expensive. So this is just to say that
and we'll see this theme over and over
that there is a little bit of a tradeoff
in terms of how much sophistication you
want to have in your algorithm versus uh
the algorithm eventually you end up
using since eventually your goal is to
get to the local minimum as fast as
possible.
So we talked a little bit about the
center action. What about alpha the step
size? Again different ways of choosing a
step size. For example, a possible way
is the so-cal minimization rule. You
among all the uh positive alphas, you
choose the one that leads you to the
largest cost reduction into your
function f sensible, but you have to
solve the minimization problem. Not
terribleizing over a scalar, but still
is a minimization problem that you want
to solve.
At the other end of the spectrum, you're
super lazy. So you just pick a number
for alpha, say 0.1, you stick with it.
It's probably the very first descent
algorithm that you would implement. You
just pick a value for alpha, you stick
for with it, and you hope for the best.
Unfortunately though
um with this choice actually the method
might diverge. So it might not converge
to a local minimum and the convergence
rate could be very slow.
So another idea that is quite popular is
a so-called diminishing step size. So
you choose an alpha
that across iterations goes to zero. So
you start with one maybe 0.5.1
0005. So basically you have a rule
whereby alpha goes to zero but
with a property that the sum over all
alphas across iteration is equal to
infinity.
So what's the deal here? The idea here
is that often time when you start the
process you are so let's look at now a
one-dimensional problem.
So you're here.
So you're quite far from the local
minimum. So at the beginning it's quite
typical to have a long step sizes. So
you make like a a big jump and maybe you
move here, then you move here, maybe
then you overshoot,
but then after a while where conceivably
you have gotten closer to local minimum,
you start making smaller and smaller
jumps so that you don't oscillate too
much around the local minimum and
eventually eventually eventually you
converge to it. So beginning very large
alpha so that you can make big progress.
But the point with large alpha is that
as you get close to the local minimum,
you can start bouncing around and
oscillating. But then you start
decreasing the alpha so that you do that
final fine tuning to really get to the
to the local minimum you care about.
But you have to be careful because if
your alpha goes to zero too quickly,
maybe you don't make enough steps toward
your local minimum. So you want to make
sure that collectively
when you sum all of the alpha actually
you may make potentially an infinite
distance so that you're guaranteed to
explore widely if necessary.
the firstation
>> in the first iteration
>> generally pure guess.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. There is quite a bit of
hyperparameter tuning.
Um
which is a good sake into this analysis.
So there is a lot of stuff that we
haven't discussed
how you choose those parameters. So for
the descent direction is a little bit
more principle. For step size is a bit
murky. It's a bit more experience.
But then in general there are three key
concepts we haven't really discussed.
The first one is how do we guarantee
that this algorithm indeed converges. So
I told you how in one step you're
guaranteed to decrease the value of the
function. But that doesn't mean
necessarily that you're guaranteed to
get to the local minimum once you
iterate across all of the iterations.
So indeed there are some properties that
one could list that ensure that you
converge to a local minimum that is so
sorry to stationary points that means a
point where the gradient is equal to
zero.
Second when do you stop?
There are different termination rules.
One might just say I'm willing to invest
100 iterations. Whatever I get after 100
iterations that's it. Or maybe
you look at the value of the function at
x k + one
and the value of the function at x k
you take the difference if this
difference is less than epsilon you just
quit and call it a day means that you're
not doing much progress anymore and so
there is no point in keeping investing
computation and then convergence rate.
So depending on the initial condition
and how actually you choose the step
size profile, what can you say about how
quickly you will converge to a
stationary point,
we could spend pretty much half of the
class on this topic. So we are skipping
on those, but I just want you to be
aware of those. And second of all, the
class of methods that I've just
discussed are referred to as
gradient methods because you use
information for the gradient. But there
are also methods that do not need or
necessarily need information from the
gradient. Those are referred to as
derivative free methods such as the
coordinate descent uh uh the coordinate
descent method that iteratively
minimizes
uh along the coordinate directions to
find the minimum of a function or or the
nether mean method that is another
clever method that doesn't require at
all any computation of derivatives. This
is just to say that uh there are there
is very re rich literature both in the
field of gradient free and non-gradian
free methods.
Any questions?
So, so far we have talked about
unconstrained optimization problems but
we are particularly interested in uh
constraint optimization problems because
as I said optimal control problems
typically have at least one constraint
which is the represented by the
dynamics.
uh as we will see the key solution to
solve the constraint optimization
problems boils down to the concept of a
lrange multiplier and actually this
concept will carry over also to the
setting of optimal control and we won't
do proofs uh here but just wanted to
give some intuition about how people
would go about proving statements about
equality constraints problem or
inequality constraint problems and
typically there are two main approaches
The first one is uh the so-called
penalty viewpoint whereby you take the
constraints
you put those constraints if you so to
speak in a cost function and you assign
a high penalty for violating them. So
basically you reduce a constraint
problem into an unconstrained one where
constraint satisfaction is viewed as a
penalty cost meaning that if you satisfy
the constraint then you have zero in the
cost. If you don't satisfy the
constraint then the cost shoots up.
That's one way. Or the other way is to
take an approach similar to the one we
have discussed in the case of
unconstrained optimization. But when we
talk about displacement,
we can't talk about arbitrary
displacement anymore because some
directions are allowed some others are
not because we have equality
constraints. So we have to have a little
more sophisticated notion of what an
allowable displacement is and based on
that derive necessary optimality
conditions.
So let's start first with the equality
constraints. So equality constraint
optimization problems are those whereby
you're still trying to minimize a
function f
over real n. So over n decision
variables subject to m equality
constraints written as hi x equals zero
and we have m of these functions.
As I said f maps rn into r and hi also
map rn into r. And here we assume that
they are both continuously
differentiable.
And just to save on some notation, I
will compactly write the set of function
h1 to hm as bold h. In general in this
class, a bold phase means vector.
So the basic result in the field of
equality constraint problems is the
lranch multiplier theorem.
That is a bit cryptic and I will provide
some intuition later on. But
mechanically it states that if XAR is a
local minimum then there exist M
numbers. M is the same number of
equality constraints. These numbers are
referred to as the lagrange multipliers
and denoted as lambda 1, lambda 2 all
the way to lambda m such that the
gradient of f plus the linear
combination of the constraint gradients
scaled by the lranch multipliers one per
constraint is equal to zero.
We I'll provide later a bit of
justification. Right now this seems a
bit uh mysterious
but
first let me show you the mechanics
about how people uh use this theorem. So
before in an strain optimization you
take the function you compute the
gradient equal to zero you find the
points that satisfy the condition and
then among those points you see which
one achieves lowest value. Great. Here
we do something similar but we don't
just set the gradient equal to zero.
That will be the case. Look how if the
number of constraint is equal to zero we
this piece goes away. So we recover the
condition gradient equal to zero. Here
is a refinement. It's not just gradient
equal to zero. It's gradient plus this
linear combination of the constraint
gradient being equal to zero.
What does that mean in practice? So
let's see. Let's assume that we have uh
this optimization problem which is
equality constraint. This is the
objective function
and uh uh this is the constraint set. So
essentially the function that we are
looking at.
So this is the plane
x1 x2.
So now the function is not mapping any
possible point into a value
but only those point that belong to the
circle.
So this is the so this is the locus of
points whereby x1 squar + x2 squar equal
to so this basically the physible
domain.
You can pick any point in here
and you want to find the one for which f
namely x1 + x2 achieves lowest value.
So mechanically what do you do?
This is a necessary optimality
condition. So you treat it the same way
as the gradient equal to zero. But now
there is that additional
term that you have to account for and
note that you also have to solve for the
lranch multipliers.
So what you do is first
you compute the gradient of f
idea of what the gradient of f is for a
generic point x1 x2.
Should I ask the ca and joke and joke?
So it's a one one
right because this remember that the
gradient
is by definition gradient of f with
respect to x1 gradient of f respect to
x2.
But f is equal to x1 + x2. So dative of
x1 + x2 with respect to x1 is equal to
1. Dative x1 plus x2 with respect to x2
is equal to 1. Okay.
So then what is the gradient of h?
So derivative of
uh x1 2 + x2 - 2 with respect to x1 is
equal to 2x1.
And for the other component is just 2
x2.
So then what you do
is that you put everything together.
And so the lranch multiply theorem it
says that if x is a minimum then
1 one plus lambda here we only have one
constraint. So we're going to have only
one lranch multiplier which I call
lambda. lambda
2 x1 2 x2 is equal to zero.
And I have to solve for x1 x2 and
lambda.
Once I solve for x1 x2 and lambda I
don't care about lambda anymore. That
was just a mechanism for me to find the
necessary optimality condition for x1
x2. I only look at the x1 x2 that had
derived
but two equations three unknowns
that's a problem do you have an idea
where the last equation can come from
equation can come from
>> the state
>> exactly so still the the necessary
condition says that x has to satisfy
this condition and of course x to has to
be physible so it has to belong to this
circle so we also have the additional
equations x1 squar + x2 squar = 2.
Okay, so now we just have to solve uh
all of this.
So we have 1 + 2 lambda x1 = 0 and 1 + 2
lambda x2 = z.
Which means
uh x1
is equal to minus over 1 / 2 lambda and
x2 is equal -1 / 2 lambda.
Now I plug x1 and x2 in here so that I
can solve for lambda.
So when I plug into the constraint, so
what I get is 1 / 4 lambda squar + 1 / 4
lambda squar = 2, which implies
2 over 4 lambda squar = 2. So this goes
away. So lambda
is equal to +
minus 12.
And then I go back here.
And what I get is uh
so if lambda is equal to 1/2
then
x1 is equal to
- one
and x2 is equal to minus1. And if lambda
is equal to minus one/2
then x1 is = 1 and x2 is = 1
for which value the function achieves
for for which pair the function achieves
lower higher sorry lower value
here. So that's a minimum.
Actually the lran multiplier does have
value but at least for the way I'm
presenting it here is just a a medium a
means to an end. So we use it to solve
for these equations but then once we get
to our local minima we just throw it
away.
So it's just the mechanics. Now I'm
going to give you a bit of intuition
about that how this works. So think
about gradient equal to zero. But now
there is this additional sophistication
where you also have to account for the
constraint gradients and you will
through the notion lranch multipliers
that are additional variables that you
solve for. The good news though is that
uh between the lrange multiplier theorem
and the equality constraints you have
the same number of variables as
equations. So you can always solve for
all of that. Of course, it can be
challenging because these might be
nonlinear algebraic equations.
Let's look graphically at what's
happening here and I'll come back to
this picture. So this is your
physible set
and these are the level set curves for
your fun for your cost function.
Remember that the cost function is f
x1 + x2.
So x1 + x2 = c defines a line in the x1
x1 x2 space. Namely the line x2 = c -
x1.
So these the one that goes through the
origin will be x2= - x1 as I go in this
direction actually have increasing
values. So this will be x1 + x2= 3 or
four five and so on and so on. So from
this
interpretation and you'll see later in a
second why this is useful.
Remember that the optimal point as we
found it is -1 - one. So that's a
minimum which makes sense because these
are the level set and we want to try to
pick the level set carve with the
possible pos the lowest possible value
but it still intersect the principal
set. So as you move you move you move
until you get here the point of tangency
here
there is no point x1 and x2 that will be
feasible with respect to the circle.
the objective would actually get a lower
value but it's not allowed.
Does it make sense?
Maybe think a little bit about this
geometric intuition because it's
important.
So again this is the constraint set.
These are the level set carves
and these will be the set of points such
as x1 + x2 is equal 5. x1 + x2 is equal
3. x1 + x2 equals zero. That would be
this curve here. And here I have a two
points for which x1 + x2 = 0. The one
here and the one.
But I can go even farther. So x1 + x2 =
-1 and so on until I get here which is
x1 + x2= -2. And I have an intersection
here. So there is at least one point
that achieve that value. If I go farther
down then there is no point that yeah
>> is there a geometric interpretation of
why we have two lambdas is that the
maximum
>> yes because that's a because remember
that this is just a a necessary
condition for a stationary point. So
it's not differentiating between it
being a maximum and minimum. And in fact
if you plug in the other lambda you get
a maximum here.
>> Would that mean that the con was
important for the
Uh no the no I mean the the constraint
is always important for the minimization
because you're only allowed to pick
point from the physible set
but
>> equals what does that mean?
>> Lambda so lambda equals zero but
remember that here the condition is not
in terms of the quality constraints is
in terms of the constraint gradients. So
that's why lambda equals 0% doesn't tell
you immediately a condition on the
equality constraint per se because to
the gradient of the constraint
but related to that
let's try to be a bit more of intuition
and essentially there are two ways at
least in my mind to interpret
um
the lanch multiplier theorem. So let's
look.
Let's look at a simple case where you
have only one constraint.
Yeah,
I I just for simplicity avoided the
parenthesis x. So what the lanch
multiplier theorem is telling us is that
the gradient of f belongs to the
subspace spanned by the constrainted
gradients at x. the the constraint
solution will be at a point of tangency
of the constraint cost curves and the
constraint function. What does that
mean? So here
what the lrange multiplier theorem is
saying is that the gradient of f is
equal to the gradient at the candidate
for optimality the gradient of f is
equal to the gradient of h times a
scalar. So basically they are colinear
but remember
that the gradients are orthogonal to the
level set carves
which means that uh if the gradient of
the level set carve refer to the
constraint set and the gradient to the
objective function are colinear it means
that those two level set carves are
tangent to each other which is really
what you have here.
So this is the situation. So we have the
circle which is the physible set.
Here we have the point
-1 - one.
The gradient
was uh
the gradient of the objective function
was 1 one
and the gradient of h
here is equal to -2 - 2.
So you see that the gradient of the
objective function and the gradient of
the constraint set are colinear which
means that the level set where the
constraint set and the level set carve
for the objective function are tangent
to each other which notionally captures
the fact that to minimize you're trying
to push your level set carve for the
objective function as much as possible
towards some
situation whereby if you push farther
you don't have intersection anymore with
your constraint set. If you could push
it even farther then you would do so.
Tangency is basically the geometric
notion that capture
uh the fact that you cannot push it
farther
some intuition here but it's actually
correct intuition
make sense
so that's the more geometric intuition
the other way that I like to think about
a multipliers is as follows that might
sound a little bit uh cryptic but
actually it's even clearer in my opinion
so the cost gradient So what a
multiplicity theorem is saying remember
it's saying that the gradient of the
cost function at a local minimum
is
a linear combination
of the gradient of the constraints.
So what that implies and we'll see in a
second. So first let me state it and
then I'll explain it. What that implies
is that the cog gradient uh gradient of
f is orthogonal to the subspace of a
first order physible variations. We
define the physible variations as those
variations that are orthogonal to the
constraint gradients.
So what is it saying? So v of xar
is the space of displacements
that are allowable up to first order.
Meaning that they lead you to a point
that is still feasible up to first
order. Specifically,
h
of xar plus delta x
is equal to h of xar
plus gradient of h times evaluated xar
time delta x.
So if you choose delta x from this set
then this term is equal to zero.
This term is also equal to zero because
we're assuming that xar is feasible
since it's a candy local minimum which
means that this is also equal to zero.
So all this is to say that uh if you
move along these displacements
you are moving away from xar
to new points that at least up to first
order
satisfy the
constraints.
But remember,
but then
if that is true, then delta f of xar
time delta x
is equal to zero thanks to the lranch
multiplier theorem. Since the gradient
of f is a linear combination of all
these uh constraint gradients and the
delta x is picked in such a way that the
scalar problem between delta x each one
of these constraint gradient is equal to
zero then I'm just uh if I replace with
a with the lambda i's gradient of h i
all this goes to zero. So what I'm
saying here is that you can view the
lagranch multiplier theorem as
essentially embodying the conditions
whereby the gradient of f has to be
orthogonal to the space of feasible
variations which is exactly what we had
in the case of unconstrained
optimization if you remember and then we
said that x can be anything and that
leads to the condition gradient equal to
zero here that cannot be anything that
tax has to be taken from this set here
and so the condition is a bit more
sophisticated is saying that the
gradient of f the most we can say has to
be orthogonal to all these data
I mean my point here is that uh what
we're doing is just a more sophisticated
way of what we did before with um
unconstrained optimization but now we
had to be more sophisticated in the
sense that we cannot reason about all
possible displacement
only those that satisfy the equality
constraints up to first order.
So this leads us to the key result here
and we will see this result showing up
again of course with some modifications
in optimal control which is a necessary
optimality condition for equality
constraint problems. So let's assume
that xar is a local minimum of f subject
to h of x=0 and assume and that's a
technical condition that the constraint
gradients are linearly independent.
Turns out that if this is not the case
actually this is no longer a necessary
optimality condition.
I don't want to elaborate too much on uh
this condition. Main point is that
always check that for a kind of
optimality the constraint gradients are
linear independent. Then there exist a
unique vector lambda 1 lambda ma granch
multiplier vector such as the gradient
of f is a linear combination to the
constraint gradients.
So a physible vector for which the
constraint gradients are linear
independent is called regular. How do we
prove this theorem is actually a little
bit convoluted but essentially can be
proved in a couple of ways. First again
as we said before penalty approach we
move the constraints to the cost
function. We penalize deviations from
feibility and then um
um
we make a limit argument to derive the
lanch multiplier theorem or and this
maybe a little bit more direct and
intuitive but actually it's a bit com
not convoluted but it's a little bit
more annoying in terms of bookkeeping.
So what you do is that you have n
variables and m equality constraints. So
you express m of the variables in terms
of the remaining n minus m
and then you reduce the problem to an
unconstrained optimization problem
and then you do three pages of analysis.
But just saying you know what the
intuition comes from. An excellent book
if you're interested in nonlinear
optimization is the book of Dimmitri
Bertikas nonlinear optimization.
If you want to learn more about
convergence rates for grad descent
methods proofs or lage multiplier
theorems
explore a little more these technical
conditions and so on
and this is again something that will
come back in optimal control. What you
do with linearly sorry with equality
constraint problems is to form the
so-called lagrion function. The lang
function is a function that comprises
your objective plus you now lift your
equality constraint into the cost and
you scale down by multipliers lambda
which are additional variables you have
to find and then you just treat the
problem as an unconstrained optimization
problem with respect to this augmented
cost function.
So then the necessary optionality
condition with respect to the lrion
becomes set the lrjen l equal to zero as
if the problem was unconstrained. And
what you get when you take the gradient
with resp to the x variables you get
exactly the lranch multiplier theorem.
So gradient of f plus sum of lambda i
gradient of hi is equal to zero. When
you take the gradient with respect to
the lambdas, you get the different
condition h1= 0, h2= 0 and so on and so
forth.
Notably, the gradient with respect to x
leads to a set of n equations. The
gradient with respect to lambda leads to
a set of m equations and we have n + m
variables. So we have n plus m variables
over n plus uh m equations. So you can
solve for that. So that's what I wanted
to say about equality constraint
problems. Next time we'll have a quick
look and this will be quite brief at the
inequality constraint case which will
lead you to the so-called KKT conditions
and then we move to into our first topic
related to optimal control.